bonsoir à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour décrypter
l'actualité contemporaine vous regardez
l'inattendu et vous êtes les bienvenus
là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la franche au fond des yeux
sinon j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en
apprennent à tricoter à votre place je
la ramène un peu moins mais si vous ne
réussissez pas ce qu'il vous manque
qu'une seule chose qu'un tout petit
détail le pari de l'ina décrypte
l'actualité
ludivine lopez géraldine corner lavaud
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste à l'ina
vous avez décortiquer les titres de la
presse et certains sujets ont plus
particulièrement retenu votre attention
divine c'est l'histoire d'alain coq qui
vous interpeller oui alain cocq
nathanaël cet homme de 57 ans atteint
d'une maladie dégénérative a décidé de
se laisser mourir en arrêtant de
s'alimenter et de se soigner
emmanuel macron avait refusé de lui
accorder le suicide est un suicide
assisté
alors cette histoire a relancé le débat
sur la fin de vie en france un débat
ancien il date de 1978 année d'une
proposition de loi c'était une première
et vous allez voir vous allez l'écouter
c'est le sénateur henri caillavet qui en
était à l'initiative
ces deux propositions de loi tente pour
une personne incurable à pouvoir refuser
l'acharnement thérapeutique
c'est à dire vivre pleinement sa mort et
à certains vous reprochent déjà
d'organiser par la loi
la mort d homme je veux organiser ma
propre mort mon corps m'appartient il
n'a personne à partir personne lorsque
par suite de circonstances et notamment
d'incurabilité je suis devenu un être
inerte végétatif
il m'appartient et à moi seul de dire si
je veux continuer à vivre de manière
artificielle c'est à dire grâce à des
pompes
grâce à l'ensemble de vecteurs de
machinerie qui maintiennent un homme pas
une existence artificiers
alors le projet d' henri caillavet sera
rejeté il faudra attendre 2005 soit 27
ans plus tard pour qu'une loi sur la fin
de vie soit votée c'est la loi léonetti
natal est la loi qui est toujours en
vigueur merci beaucoup tout autre chose
géraldine vous avez décidé de nous
parler de la victoire d'un français en
formule 1 ça n'arrive pas tous les jours
c'était dimanche cela faisait 24 ans que
cela n'était plus arrivé pourquoi avoir
choisi cette information géraldine alors
vous venez de le dire à nathanaël cela
faisait 24 ans qu'on n'avait pas vu un
français sur un podium de formule 1 et
24 ans petit clin d'oeil à 1 c'est l'âge
de pierre galy qui a donc remporté ce
grand prix d'italie et en cherchant un
petit peu dans nos archives on est
retombé sur sa première télé et déjà il
était présenté comme un futur champion
on regarde à 13h30 pierre galy de f gaz
comme cez est un pilote de karting qui
fait parler de lui un surdoué
il est plutôt petit et fait de mieux en
france dans sa catégorie ça fait cinq
ans qui roulait en cinq ans il est
devenu d'une des stars françaises de ce
sport avec il est ambitieux il sait ce
qu'il veut son rêve un volant de formule
1 c'est un garçon
malgré son âge qui a déjà beaucoup de
maturité voilà et on lui souhaite en
tout cas de devenir le prochain champion
du monde français de formule 1 après
alain prost exact il ya plus de 24 ans
en tout cas ça c'était pour l'acte eu
des derniers jours mais sinon que s'est
il passé le 9 septembre
ces dernières années on remonte le temps
avec le zapping de l'ina ça s'est passé
à 9 septembre et à des années
différentes regarder
ce matin 10 heures 4 heures de l'après
midi à pékin la radio chinoise annonce
la mort du président mao tsé toung
aussitôt des hommes et des femmes
sortent dans la rue en pleurant la chine
est en deuil
ces images de propagande et d'unité qui
semble d'une autre époque
et pourtant la corée du nord fêtait hier
le 40e anniversaire de la création de
son régime
[Musique]
à la lettre b dans le petit larousse on
trouve donc désormais aux côtés de
bacchus dieu du vin paul bocuse dieu de
la cuisine le chancelier schröder en
tête toute l'allemagne qui compte
découvre en exclusivité le plus grand
musée juif d'europe
ce musée retrace les deux millénaires de
présence des juifs en allemagne
bon vent à vsd vsd ces vendredi samedi
dimanche le nouvel hebdomadaire que
lance maurice siégel la ville est calme
est presque silencieuse
seuls les scooters électriques et les
voitures électriques ont droit de cité
tous les véhicules non polluants sont
sortis des plus traditionnels aux plus
iconoclaste
chaque année depuis cinq ans une
cinquantaine de concurrents français et
étrangers s'affrontent sur trois
épreuves dans les rues de lussac
saint-émilion
bonsoir et à demain vous êtes des
millions à l'avoir expérimenté cette
année le télétravail a débarqué dans
votre vie au milieu du mois de mars
lorsque le confinement a été mise en
place
un salarié sur trois a découvert les
avantages les inconvénients d'organiser
sa vie professionnelle à son domicile
loin de ses collègues
loin de son bureau géraldine corner
lavaud depuis quand le télétravail
existe-t-il alors dans les archives de
la télévision française en tout cas ça
remonte vous allez être surpris aux
années 70 et willy soixante années 70
c'est surprenant parce que c'est avant
même bien avant la démocratisation
d'internet et aussi des ordinateurs un
domestique alors c'était pas en france
maternelle c'était au royaume uni dans
une entreprise de programmeurs donc déjà
plutôt à l'aise avec les outils
informatiques
une pratique tellement étonnante à
l'époque que la télévision française y
consacre une émission entière regardez
cet extrait madame wharton semble vivre
la vie d'une femme au foyer sans
profession apparemment elle est
simplement une ménagère une ménagère qui
quelques heures par jour révèle sa
double personnalité
car si certains ont chez eux un bureau
dans leur appartement
madame wharton elle a un terminal
d'ordinateur un simple coup de téléphone
et en quelques minutes elle va redevenir
ingénieurs géraldine comment justifie
t'elle ce choix du télétravail alors
dans l'émission elle explique très
clairement pour elle et pour d'autres
femmes de son entreprise
le télétravail c'est le moyen de
travailler dans une grosse boîte qui
était situé à londres tout en vivant à
la campagne est de pouvoir aussi
s'occuper de ses enfants
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est donc
dans ce reportage outre l'innovation
technologique les journalistes de
l'époque met en avant aussi tout de
suite les limites du télétravail
écoutez gili a je pense un inconvénient
quand vous travaillez dans un bureau
quand vous sortez du bureau vous n'y
pensez plus vous coupez le contact
moi je ne peux pas le faire ce travail
en veille la maison en quelque sorte on
ne peut jamais savoir si quelqu'un ne va
pas téléphoné le soir ou pendant la
journée n'importe quoi et j'ai le
sentiment d'être toujours sur le qui
vive
voilà ça c'est pour l'angleterre début
des années 70 et en france alors quand
est ce que le télétravail
arrive alors en france 1 il faut
attendre le début des années 80 pouvoir
émerger seulement l'idée du télétravail
il y a des bourgs
il y à des contres côté contre 1 sociaux
psychanalyste voici ce qu'il en pensait
on sait très bien que plus d'une
personne et tisanes et puis d'une
personne seule et des plus elle risque
de
névroses et plus elle est angoissée plus
elle a progressivement un peu peur de
tout si bien que finalement des
personnes comme ça qui sont placés dans
un cadre très restreint bon finalement
petit à petit je dis bien dans la
majorité des cas pas toujours des dégâts
sera petit c est avoir de plus en plus
peur du contact avec les autres et fait
rêver à votre sociaux psychanalyste il y
avait quand même des salariés qui
étaient favorables au télétravail à
l'époque où il y avait des pour un
surtout que plus les années passent plus
la technologie évolue puis les
communications deviennent de plus en
plus facile et donc plus le télétravail
passe d'un mirage à quelque chose qui
devient concret réel donc en 1985 c'est
un des tout premiers sujets jt sur cette
pratique donc une femme qui fait du
télétravail l'argument phare à l'époque
pour le journaliste je vous dis que
laisse découvrir qui sait c'était que le
télétravail permettait aux mamans de
rester à la maison
en l'écoutant le micro informatique a
longtemps été considéré dans l'esprit de
certains scientifiques comme une sorte
de miracle devant améliorer notre vie
quotidienne à la maison et dans le
travail et c'est ainsi qu'est né ce que
l'on appelle le télétravail
il permet à certains et notamment aux
femmes de rester à la maison du travail
et domicile
là vous avez bien sûr reconnu noël
mamère sur le plateau d'antenne de midi
l'ancien du 13 heures travaillées
s'occuper des enfants du foyer tient
géraldine on va en parler dans un
instant avec ludivine lopez est notre
invité dans le dossier consacré à la
charge mentale mais d'abord on reste sur
le télétravail avec vous dans les années
80 début 90 cette pratique reste encore
ultra marginal dans notre pays oui
vraiment très mal c'est difficile
d'avoir des chiffres mais en 1993 il ya
un sujet jt qui recense seulement 2000
télétravailleurs en france est vraiment
peu et il faudra attendre un événement
bien particulier
si je vous dis la tonnelle 1995 retraite
je m'en souviens comme si c'était hier
je commençais à travailler à france
télévisions figurez-vous les grèves 1 le
bras de fer entre le gouvernement et les
cheminots pendant deux mois les
transports ont été à l'arrêt et on a
souvent dû marcher moi j'avais une mob
oui c'est ça la france était paralysé
quasi impossible de se rendre au travail
sauf si on avait une mobylette donc une
solution
encore une fois je vous laisse écouter
en revanche la grève a permis à
certaines entreprises d'expérimenter de
nouvelles technologies et de mettre en
oeuvre deux
belle façon de travailler et puis en ce
moment à paris avec donc les mouvements
de grève il est un peu difficile pour
certaines entreprises de travailler sauf
sauf quand elle utilise le télétravail
ces trois semaines de grève relance
l'idée du travail à distance le
télétravail le président du conseil
régional michel giroux souhaite
développer cette nouvelle méthode de
travail en ile-de-france alors question
est ce qu'après ces mouvements sociaux
le travail le télétravail s'est
développée en france n'ont pas vraiment
les années passent les communications
sont moins chers internet est beaucoup
plus puissant les ordinateurs portables
investissent tous les domiciles presque
mais le travail le télétravail pardon
tombe peu à peu dans l'oubli
il faudra attendre 2009 pour une autre
crise une sonnerie sanitaire cette fois
ci je crois que c'était la grippe a
exactement et avec la crainte de
pandémie certaines entreprises prennent
leurs dispositions pour assurer une
continuité
ce sont des mots est une technique qui
nous fait penser à ce que l'on veut
puisque l'ont violé avec la crise du coc
vide alors la solution effectivement
c'était encore une fois le télétravail
tel salarié n'est pas atteinte de la
grippe a mais depuis un mois fait partie
du plan de continuité d'activité mises
en place par son entreprise et pour elle
hormis les rapports humains et qui lui
manque que le télétravail possède
beaucoup davantage face à un scénario
probable de pandémie ne pas ça s'est
imposé avec le risque de pandémie
puisque intellectuellement on avait une
certaine réticence parce que c'est
toujours bien de voir les collaborateurs
là il ya de la communication où ils
peuvent se faire aider
puis voilà il ya une ambiance de travail
alors le confinement cette année à
dynamiser le recours au télétravail
mais est ce que cette pratique va
s'installer durablement en france
d'après l'observatoire du télétravail
mise en place par le commissariat
général à l'égalité des territoires
en temps normal 1 hors crise sanitaire
il y entre 8 et 10 7% de
télétravailleurs en france contre 30 à
35 % dans les pays du nord de l'europe
et la france a encore une belle marge de
progression dans ce secteur merci
beaucoup
géraldine autre dossier
particulièrement sensible la question de
la charge mentale vous avez certainement
entendu parler mais vous ne savez
peut-être parce que c est bien notre
invité va tout vous expliquer et s'est
invité sept
aurélia schneider psychiatre spécialisé
dans les thérapies comportementales et
cognitives
bonsoir docteur en 2018 vous avez publié
ce livre sur la charge mentale aux
éditions larousse un sujet dont on parle
beaucoup depuis quelques années
concrètement docteur c'est quoi la
charge mentale la charge mentale c'est
le fait d'avoir à s'occuper de choses
qui se passent dans un endroit alors
qu'on n'y est pas autrement dit votre
cerveau est encombré par une
simultanéité de choses à faire c'est pas
tant la double journée c'est déjà ça
mais c'est des choses à faire au même
moment qui se passe dans des endroits
différents et qui encombrent votre
espace psychique pensé à tout tout le
temps lunéville leur place vous qui avez
un oeil sur les archives de la
télévision française depuis quand
parle-t-on de cette charge mentale
eh bien figurez-vous qu'on en parle
depuis le milieu des années 60 dans les
médias alors à cette période on ne
parlait pas bien évidemment de charge
mentale est plutôt vous l'avez dit dr
schneider de double journée de la femme
de charges domestiques
rappelons qu'à cette époque la société
commence à changer les femmes sont de
plus en plus nombreuses à entrer dans le
monde du travail
mais le partage des tâches à la maison
elle reste encore assez déséquilibré une
sociologue en parlait déjà dans les
années 60 elle s'appelait pierre est
certain elle en parlait justement sur un
plateau de télévision en 1964 écoutez la
ce travail qu'elle accomplit ce dans des
conditions généralement difficile et
très lourde constitue pour elle une à la
fois une forme d'esclavagé et une forme
d'émancipation des esclavages en ce sens
qu'elles font un nombre d'heures de
travail que pense un homme ne fait et ne
supporterai de faire puisque alors
travail professionnel elle ajoute le
travail domestique ce qui représente au
minimum 80 heures par semaine d'après
les enquêtes et des études qui ont été
faites
ludivine aujourd'hui est-ce que ce
surmenage quotidien est encore une
affaire de femme ni
oui en grande majorité la preuve avec
ces chiffres regarder en 2018 un sondage
révèle que 63 % des femmes interrogées
considéraient être davantage touchés par
la charge mentale contre 36% des hommes
moi j'avais une question docteurs je
n'ai d'art à vous poser est ce que c'est
un constat que vous faites auprès de vos
patients aussi déjà en tant que
psychiatre on voit plus souvent de
femmes que d'hommes
donc c'est difficile de d'équilibré mon
discours mais les femmes que je reçois
sont beaucoup en difficultés pour gérer
à la fois le travail à la fois la maison
et elle déclare souvent qu'elles sont
aidés par des conjoints
la plupart du temps les hommes sont
bonnes volontés le problème c'est plutôt
l'initiative c'est qu'elle reste
décisionnaire et organisatrice grosso
modo l'intendance et choix aux femmes
souvent très souvent
dr est ce que vous observez quand même
davantage d'hommes dans votre cabinet
pour ce problème justement et comment
vous expliquer justement que les hommes
aujourd'hui arrive t'on en nombre plus
grand nombre qu'avant en tout cas alors
en fait les gens viennent pas consulté
pour charge mentale
les gens viennent consulter parce que
ils sont épuisés parce que si l'on voit
là et savent pas ce que c'est ils ont
ils ont l'impression d'avoir le temps de
rien d'être toujours en train de courir
et on s'aperçoit que ils sont souvent
assez perfectionniste qui sont souvent
en difficulté avec la gestion du temps
et des titres preuves estime de soi et
du coup on est en difficultés pour gérer
tout ce qu'on doit faire
si on doit le faire parfaitement si on
doit le faire en arrivant pas bien a
compté son temps donc les hommes peuvent
aussi être complètement touché par ça il
ya des hommes qui sont divorcés qui ont
charge des enfants et qui est se
débrouille très bien et qui sont obligés
de gérer le pédiatre la baby sitter leur
boulot etc etc
alors on l'a vu tout à l'heure dans les
années 60 ludivine des sociologues
décrivait déjà sans forcément savoir que
c'était la charge mentale
mais cette double journée est ce que des
femmes ont parlé à la télévision
à l'époque alors oui mais à partir des
années 70 plus tôt à cette époque les
femmes travailleuses sont de véritable
phénomène de société qui intéresse les
journalistes
certains leur accordait des reportages
des reportages entier leur donnait la
parole et je voulais vous montrer un
reportage ils datent de 1975 et selon
moi il illustre déjà très bien sans la
nommer bien sûr la notion de charge
mentale on regarde lorsque chaque jour à
5h30 maggie quitte son travail analystes
dans un centre d'informatique de
l'éducation nationale sa journée est
loin d'être terminée pendant le trajet
elle a le temps de récapituler ce qui
l'attend à son retour des courses pour
le dîner la cuisine pour 4 daniel son
mari katherine 11 ans actuellement en
classe de neige et stéphane deux ans en
rentrant le soir je suis plus ou moins
fatigués énervé j'ai eu des contrariétés
à mon travail ça n'a pas toujours marché
comme j'ai voulu la maison s'en ressent
l'auteur schneider je veux faire
travailler un petit peu vous avez
entendu cette femme elle parle
d'énervement l'héritabilité de fatigue
face au quotidien est ce que ce sont les
symptômes de la charge mentale je peux
pas dire que ce sont les symptômes de la
charge mentale parce que la charge
mentale et gérer parfois très très bien
par certaines personnes vous le dire des
gens qui ne se plaignent de rien en
revanche on peut très bien se sentir
surchargé et on peut très bien se sentir
à la limite c'est à dire avoir des
voûtes est avoir des mots globalement
dans tout le corps on peut avoir une
irritabilité des troubles du sommeil une
fatigue très importante et décrit
d'ailleurs dans leur voilà exactement et
et comment ne pas être fatigué d'hier
qui a la double journée et on voit un
truc très intéressants ont la voix qui
sur sa mobylette est en train de
réfléchir à ce qu'elle va devoir faire
et on exactement là dedans c'est à dire
vous avez oubliez une obligation de
planifier et dès lors que vous êtes là
dedans c'est une charge alors
effectivement on peut quelquefois arrivé
loin trop loin au burn out
alors on est d'accord je vais vous dire
on est d'accord la charge mentale n'est
pas une maladie en revanche elle peut
entraîner provoquer les choses graves
des maladies graves chez les patients
la principale c'est le burn-out même si
c'est pas bien géré et effectivement à
un moment vous ne pouvez pas tout faire
et le burn out c'est pas une dépression
approuvant par laisser un mot on ne peut
plus on ne peut plus avancer
c'est très intéressant de voir que quand
on ne peut plus avancer qu'est ce qui se
passe mais en fait plus rien
alors qu'on s'était justement attachés à
tout faire à tout faire parfaitement et
donc c'est recréer un équilibre plutôt
que de se retrouver complètement laminé
on va remonter encore un petit peu dans
le temps avec avec ludivine vous avez
d'autres archives justement qui qui
parlent de cette charge montagne on
reste dans les années 70 oui car en plus
des témoignages dans les années soixante
dix il y avait aussi des femmes qui
dénonçait déjà ses doubles journées
c'était le cas dans ce long reportage en
1978 cette comédienne parlait par
exemple d'un conditionnement de la femme
à s'occuper de tout tout le temps
écoutez là c'est moi sont assez forts
disons que nous les femmes par des cons
et petit enfant une petite fille on nous
apprend surtout à ne pas l'être à penser
toujours aux autres avant de penser à
soi c'est une très belle idée c'est très
bien soit mais nous c'est notre mort
quotidienne c'est l'infirmière universel
quoi on on s'occupe de tout on soigne on
résout on organisons on est toujours là
aurélia schneider les mots de cette
femme en 1978 lorsqu'elle parle
d'infirmières universel ça vous inspire
quoi
oui oui oui j'avais un moment un petit
un petit mot pour faire rire un peu mes
amis je disais finalement les femmes
elles sont des infirmières plus ou moins
nu sur leur blouse et en fait il y en a
qui sont un peu plus dans la fantaisie
dans heureusement qu'ils se récupère en
disant stop ça suffit maintenant on va
où trouver autre chose que de faire son
ménage ou vous savez celle le soir et on
va aller se coucher par exemple ou alors
on attend désespérément que la machine
est fini de tourner pour étendre le
linge avant qu'il ne soit complètement
tire-bouchonné le lendemain matin et je
crois que de temps en temps il faut
faire un petit peu de fantaisie
alors on vient d'entendre des
témoignages très fort ludivine est ce
que ces femmes étaient soutenus dans les
années 70 oui elle l'était par les
mouvements féministes bien sûr mais
aussi par certaines personnalités
politiques en 1973 par exemple arlette
laguiller figure du parti
lutte ouvrière ne mâchait pas ses mots
sur le sujet écoutez la la double
journée de la femme c'est pas une
formule
pour les élections c'est une réalité
quotidienne c'est que les femmes non
seulement elle se lève peut-être encore
plus tôt que les hommes pour préparer
les enfants finir le ménage ou ou laver
ou repasser ou faire tout ce que vous
voulez qu'elles ont pas eu le temps de
faire la veille
et quand elle rentre le soir c'est la
hantise de faire les courses de faire
leurs pas voilà c'est ça la vie de la
femme travailleuse à la roulette
laguiller chef de file de lutte ouvrière
première femme à se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle c'était en
1974 ludivine il faut pourtant attendre
2017 soit près de 50 ans pour mettre un
mot sur ce mal le terme charge mentale
apparaît enfin
oui c'est en 2010 est seulement qu'un
terme vient enfin définir ce que des
femmes on l'a vu décrivait depuis des
décennies on le doit à la dessinatrice
emma sur son blog elle mettait en mots
et en images la charge mentale
la révélation le déclic est immédiat
pour des milliers de personnes qui se
reconnaissent dans ces défunts emma en
parler sur le plateau du 13 heures de
france 2 heures 2017 le loger le plus
entendu c'est merci parce que enfin
cette chose ah non ça veut dire que les
femmes qui souffraient ça avant tombait
souvent dans des disputes et maintenant
elles savent que c'est quelque chose qui
existe qu'on partage et dont on peut
discuter et peut-être faire quelque
chose lancé les actions pour équilibrer
les choses
dr schneider vous également avaient
observé un changement entre le avant et
le après cette intervention des mains
ben je sais pas si c'est un changement
en tout cas une prise de conscience
nécessaire indispensable merci encore à
emma d'avoir travaillé là dessus quand
arlette laguiller parle de hantise c'est
un mot très fort et je crois que c'est
vraiment important de réaliser à quel
point c'est difficile de tout gérer
qu'il faut s'y mettre tous et il faut
participer ensemble à la vie de la
maison s'en est aperçu pendant le
confinement je crois qu'il faut vraiment
continuer ludivine une dernière h
archives pour clore ce dossier
oui car vous en parlez dans votre livre
dr schneider vous donner même des
conseils pour faire face à la charge
mentale et bien une certaine simone de
beauvoir en faisaient autant nous sommes
en 1985
c'est sur le plateau de l'émission
aujourd'hui la vie
diffusé à l'époque sur antenne 2 je vous
propose d'écouter simone de beauvoir on
dit toujours que la solitude pour les
femmes c'est si triste est que le soir
une femme seule pleure sur ces petits
jeux sur le plat mais je crois qu'elle
est beaucoup plus contente quand elle a
un moment pour se recueillir pour se
reprendre après une journée de travail
que celles établies de servir quatre
mots mais à marie et qui lui laisse même
pas latin le temps presque de manger par
conséquent je crois que c'est une option
qu'il faut proposer à toutes les femmes
je ne dis pas de ne pas se marier le
barber d'enfants mais de réserve est
toujours une certaine zone de liberté de
solitude que ce soit pour rêver pour
lire pour écouter de la musique pour
penser pour n'importe quoi mais enfin
une zone de solitude et de liberté elle
a les mots de simone de beauvoir sur
antenne 2 en 1985 merci beaucoup aurélia
schneider pour vos explications pour
votre éclairage rappel le titre votre
livre de votre livre la charge mentale
des femmes et celle des hommes
également cette aux éditions larousse
l'inattendu touche à sa fin on se quitte
avec une petite pépite de la télévision
française cette semaine une chanson de
1958 et qui reste totalement d'actualité
et vous allez comprendre pourquoi
[Musique]
on se retrouve mercredi prochain 21h sur
le canal 27 et toute la semaine sur les
réseaux sociaux de france info et de
linars bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]